hey guys Perry here with another
Collider interview straight from
Sundance courtesy of the Kia Telluride
huge thanks to them because we want to
spread some love for some movies at
Sundance that we love so much this year
and feels weird saying I love the lodge
but I mean I love horror so it makes
sense I love the lodge I saw it last
night you all did a fantastic job thank
you so much for being here with us today
I want to start by talking to you to
hear because I need to know where did
this idea come from I mean it doesn't
surprise me all that much coming off of
goodnight mommy that you would conjure
up something like this but what sparked
the initial story here actually the
initial story is written by a Scottish
screenwriter and was offered to us by it
was offered to us by by Hema film and
yeah we kind of liked the story
obviously and yeah I like the ending
didn't work quite well when we got got
the script so we kind of yeah we also
kind of rewrote it I'm so curious ending
would have been but we have to talk
about that later I'm not gonna spoil
anything and I'm actually gonna leave it
to you guys as well to just explain to
our viewers what the lodge is about
because I don't want to go too far with
that it's about a hmm girl whoo woman
whoo it's hard to believe who goes to a
lodge with her boyfriend and his
children and the woman and the children
get left in the lodge alone and it
doesn't go very well it's a very great
heydo I'm assuming you haven't seen
goodnight mommy but if you have
she's going to believe you right now
have you really she's more mature than
oh wow are you into are you into scary
movies yeah I love scary man what's the
scariest movie you've ever seen again
the most appropriate answer imaginable
so having seen goodnight mommy now do
you both say I'm ready to like jump into
another you know cinematic experience of
Darkness like that are you open to
things like that yeah I had a lot of fun
filming this movie I would do the lodge
- don't know what that would look like
more curiosities now so if you had a lot
of fun doing it I'm assuming I mean
there actually are a bit of lighter
moments in the movie is specifically
with the siblings - and Jaden's not here
today but can you tell us a little bit
about working with Jayden and striking
up what felt like a really honest
friendship and also a sibling
relationship it was so easy to get to
know him he was so like funny and nice
from but when we first like met and got
to know each other and we were like
basically the only kids there and we
kind of filmed out in the middle of
nowhere so we would hang out all the
time was it freezing there very I would
assume so I also wanted to know a little
bit about shooting a specific scene and
if we could talk a little bit about the
scene out on the ice too because also
just the complications of doing
something like that you think about the
cold weather you think about falling
through the a/o every day
how long does something like that take
to shoot and what are the biggest
challenges that come with doing a stunt
like that I mean I don't know I think
the biggest challenge was that we always
had insisted on doing it like on
location because we're like we're like
directors who try to get as many things
like real as possible because we think
that making a film is hard enough if you
have to make and fake like make
everything up fake everything I think
it's really hard to get it like right so
we like actors or an actress who is
afraid of the ice
being scared for example they would like
if I didn't like if we were shooting and
I wasn't if it was like after lunch or
something and I wasn't like really cold
they would make me go sit lay in the
snow in the woods keep rolling and then
they'd go inside and set up the shot
this was also the perfect place to
premiere a movie like this because I
could feel it I could barely feel my
hands when I walked into that screening
last night and then they go up there I'm
like wow the thing that's really creepy
about the ice though is you can hear
this like tone of it existing or like
cry sometimes you can hear cracks when
you're on it and I'm still not convinced
that it's like this and there were like
it was safe but there was like puddles
sometimes like there was like segments
it was completely safe but on a lighter
note how is it working with the dog
actually another question - regarding
the dog was the shining and influence
here because I kept getting those vibes
throughout the movie especially with
what happens towards the end and then
the dog's name is Grady actually that
was that was not intentional but like we
thought of it like later on like we read
in script and and how funny it is like
Grady
but the director photography is like a
huge fan of the shining and actually we
preparing the lodge we watched it like
in an empty huge hotel like at night
time and had a really good time doing it
maybe it wasn't purposed by the Scottish
screenwriter we never asked him because
he named the dog Grady but maybe it's
his kind of it was his decision I don't
know the hotel we stayed at looked like
The Shining sounds like my kind of house
were so long you could see like you have
to go see the real shining hotels that's
like one heck of an experience staying
there before we have to close this out
we have game at Collider called would
you rather normally we ask questions
about making the movies but today we're
doing Sundance specific questions so
picking between the two options and
telling me why you would choose one or
the other first
would you rather see your movie before
its big festival premiere or see it for
the very first time the night it
premieres neither do you know like
watching your stuff sometimes I don't
know I don't I find I find it to be like
an uncomfortable experience I can never
rewatch an interview I did I can just
share it on so just the point so I
totally get it
um I feel like it's easier to do
interviews once you've seen the movie so
that was like a little bit hard but it
was really exciting to see it for the
first time with everyone yeah I think
also the midnight screening because
that's my first time doing something
like that was really fun because you
have the whole the whole crowd is very
reactive so that that was that was fun
an unforgettable vibe in those returns
would you just question also for us
here's one for you
would you rather would you rather test
screen your movie or would you rather
just go with your gut I think it's a
longer answer to the question no I don't
like test screenings at all so yeah but
like we screen films but not we think
it's easier like just for a few people
and you have huge room with 400 people I
think it might be really really
difficult and and hard to see what it
like but you can take out of such as
Queen so we'd prefer to screen for fewer
people and yeah take what we what we
think what we think is right yes would
you rather walk around Sundance with no
gloves or wet boots no gloves no gloves
no gloves
smart move I learned that the hard way
the other day
would you rather would you rather get to
see only your most anticipated film at a
festival or would you rather get five
tickets but two movies that you know
nothing about five tickets to movies I
know I have tickets five tickets no I'll
just do one film is the one what's the
one film on your list I think we
wouldn't be able to watch anything like
we just watched our film and have
tomorrow so no film at all that's it
that's a bummer but for anyone else
that's here and wants a good midnight
movie the lodge is obviously a priority
would you rather lose your luggage on
the way to a film festival or catch a
cold at a film festival luggage catch a
cold I'm with you good - cool they would
like a severe fear of losing my luggage
three weeks of editing with just one
t-shirt yeah I guess that's a good place
to be if you lose your luggage just in
an editing suite I drove I traveled to
Russia and lost my suitcase and didn't
get it - like the day before we went
back home so I had to wear my sister's
oversized clothes the whole time we were
there it's a good thing you have a good
sister there before we close this out I
am a huge horror fan and I love watching
a movie and getting a good fleeting
thrill out of it but it's really special
when you get to 12 most people wouldn't
call it special but I like to take a
movie home with me and I like when a
movie like this keeps me awake at night
so from your perspective what do you
hope people go home from seeing the
lodge with I personally went home and
just kept thinking about it and you know
thinking how creepy and everything that
had to happen and so I guess that's what
I hope for people to do just ponder on
it
lose countless nights of sleep over it
people came up to us yesterday and they
said thank you for not making us sleep
tonight so we're totally with you I
think this is the kind of movies we like
to make and also to experience something
that keeps your brain working I mean
it's very hard to specifically say what
we want people to think because I think
everyone sees his or her own movie
anyway so if it's open enough that there
is something that keeps working in your
brain and keeps going I think that's the
great thing and whatever that might be I
mean that's I think different for each
and every one watching it totally agree
with that
anything
that was beautiful were you able to
shake this character off at all
uh yeah i mean i yeah i yes i was a bit
like in the retreat like in
chronological order as far as possible
so it was quite it went quite downhill
so to speak yeah but that was actually
really helpful is that it was in it shot
in sequence which is helpful to my a
fascinating character to track so i'm
glad you had that opportunity a huge
congratulations to you guys again quite
the start to my midnight movies here at
Sundance thank you guys so much for
watching this interview as always please
like and share it another special shout
out to Kia Telluride for making this
happen we will see you soon with more
Sundance interviews
you